Les révolutions du monde arabe
ont suscité d'immenses espoirs.
Au nom de la justice sociale
et de la liberté,
les peuples de Tunisie, d'Égypte,
de Libye chassaient leurs dictateurs.
Dans les rues, sur les places
des printemps arabes, des femmes,
des jeunes diplômés, des citadins,
des jeunes des campagnes
ou des usines appelaient la démocratie.
Le temps était à la liesse,
mais à la guerre aussi.
Les révolutionnaires filmaient
les manifestations,
comme les émeutes ou les assauts
avec leurs téléphones portables et
postaient les vidéos sur internet.
Le monde suivait, fasciné,
le réveil de ces peuples.
Ces révolutions 2.0.
2 ans après,
le temps de l'espoir semble loin.
Dans tous les pays,
le chaos s'est installé.
Que sont devenus les rêves de liberté,
de démocratie, de justice sociale ?
Que reste-t-il des slogans
des printemps arabes de 2011 ?
L'idéal révolutionnaire
a-t-il été trahi ?
Les révolutions arabes ont commencé
le 17 décembre 2010 en Tunisie,
quand un vendeur ambulant s'est immolé
par le feu devant le bureau du gouverneur
de la petite ville de Sidi Bouzid.
Il venait de remplir sa charrette
des fruits et légumes
qu'il venait vendre
à la sauvette.
Le seul métier
qu'il avait trouvé pour survivre.
Comme beaucoup de jeunes de cette
province rurale du centre de la Tunisie.
Par son geste, par son désespoir,
il a incarné la crise du monde rural,
la honte de tous ces jeunes de
vivre dans la misère sans avenir.
Son geste désespéré est l'étincelle
des printemps arabes.
Elle allumera la révolte, les premières
manifestations que rien ne pourra arrêter.
La vague de protestation née à Sidi Bouzid
est reprise par les villes ouvrières,
puis gagne Tunis en quelques jours.
Ce sont des jeunes d'abord,
qui n'appartiennent ni à des partis
ni à des organisations syndicales,
mais qui comprennent
la détresse de Bouazizi.
Ils sont vite soutenus par les avocats,
puis par tout le peuple.
Dans la rue, les Tunisiens,
grisés par leur nombre,
découvrent la puissance
de la foule en colère.
Dans ce petit pays du Maghreb, la
dictature était insupportable.
Le président Ben Ali
asservissait son peuple
et détournait les milliards
depuis 24 ans.
- On veut qu'il dégage !
Qu'il dégage ! Qu'il dégage !
La répression de la police va faire
338 morts et plus de 2000 blessés.
- Je dis à la police :
Notre combat est aussi le vôtre
Les enfants qui ont faim
sont aussi vos enfants.
Vos fils sont aussi au chômage.
et ont perdu leur dignité.
- Vive la liberté et la dignité !
Après 4 semaines de manifestations de
sit-in, de décembre 2010 à janvier 2011,
les Tunisiens réussissent l'impensable.
Ils chassent un dictateur.
Ben Ali s'enfuit le 14 janvier 2011
en Arabie saoudite,
un mois après
les premières manifestations.
Mohamed Bouazizi, le vendeur ambulant,
n'a pas survécu à ses blessures.
Il est mort en pleine révolution et n'a
jamais connu la portée de son acte.
Le 25 janvier 2011,
10 jours après la chute de Ben Ali,
le peuple égyptien,
désespéré par la crise économique,
le chômage et la corruption,
va marcher vers la place Tahrir,
la place de la
Libération.
- Le peuple réclame
la chute du régime !
La révolution égyptienne
suit la révolte tunisienne,
mais elle est plus violente,
plus inventive.
Elle sera la révolution
d'un pays de 90 millions d'habitants
qui vont chasser leur dictateur
Hosni Moubarak, au pouvoir depuis 40 ans.
On n'est pas armé !
Les jeunes qui symbolisent
la révolution égyptienne
appartiennent à la classe
moyenne éduquée.
Le monde occidental se reconnaît en eux,
dans leur langage
et dans leurs idéaux.
Parmi eux, certains vont devenir
les premiers martyrs de la Révolution.
Leur mort va souder le peuple
égyptien contre le régime.
- Lorsque les médicaments
venaient à manquer à la mosquée,
nous en empruntions à l'église qui
se trouve à 200 mètres d'ici et inversement.
Les musulmans avaient accès à l'église
pour y recevoir les premiers soins.
Et cela fait partie des plus beaux cadeaux
que la révolution nous ait offert.
La fusion du peuple égyptien,
toutes communautés confondues.
- Nous étions une seule et même équipe.
Leurs docteurs venaient dans notre hôpital
et les nôtres allaient chez eux.
On se passait des médicaments
et de l'équipement,
tout ce dont on avait besoin.
Ce qui nous a surpris,
c'est qu'une fois soignés,
ils retournaient se battre et ensuite
ils revenaient à nouveau blessés.
On les suppliait de rentrer chez eux
"Vous êtes vraiment en danger"
"Au nom de Dieu, s'il vous plaît,
écoutez-nous"
Nous avons été très touchés par l'état
d'esprit de ces jeunes gens.
C'étaient des moments incroyables.
Je veux changer les choses
C'est pourquoi je suis place Tarhir
Dans cette Egypte qui vit sous état
d'urgence depuis 30 ans.
La peur a disparu.
Les jeunes de Tahrir
campent sur la place
et s'organisent un monde de liberté
qu'ils n'avaient jamais connu.
Cette jeunesse égyptienne
rêve de démocratie
sans pour autant penser
aux lendemains politiques.
Moubarak doit partir, c'est tout.
Le clip Soult Al Houria,
"La voix de la liberté"
devient l'hymne de la Révolution.
La place Tahrir symbolise la révolution,
pourtant, elle ne la représente pas.
Les jeunes militants urbains et diplômés
de la Révolution 2.0,
n'ont rien à voir avec l'Égypte profonde
qui veut bien se débarrasser de Moubarak,
mais cherche surtout à gagner sa vie.
Le dictateur va chercher
à gagner du temps.
Il mise sur le réveil
de l'Égypte profonde.
C'est à elle qu'il va s'adresser et
promettre de nouvelles élections.
- Ma première responsabilité aujourd'hui,
c'est de rétablir la sécurité
et la stabilité du pays pour effectuer
une transition pacifique
dans un climat favorable à la protection
de l'Égypte et des Égyptiens.
Nous transmettrons les responsabilités à
celui qui sera choisi par le peuple
au moment des prochaines élections.
Moubarak refuse de considérer les millions
de manifestants qui demandent son départ.
Il veut diviser le peuple
et demande aux chameliers
qui promènent les touristes
autour des pyramides
de foncer sur Tahrir
pour faire place nette.
Les chameliers ruinés par la révolution qui
a fait fuir les touristes, lancent l'assaut.
Les manifestants, surpris, ripostent.
C'est la licence de chamelier
d'un des attaquants.
Ils sont venus des pyramides
de Nazlet-al-Semman pour nous attaquer
L'Égypte révolutionnaire
s'impose dans ses batailles
face à d'autres Égyptiens miséreux
payés par le pouvoir.
La révolution est en marche.
Elle n'a jamais été aussi forte.
Le peuple réclame
la chute du régime !
En 2 semaines,
la violence fait plus de 800 morts.
Malgré ses victimes, les jeunes de Tahrir
refusent de lâcher prise
devant la détermination de la masse,
le dictateur plie enfin.
Le 11 février 2011, le vice-président
annonce la démission d'Hosni Moubarak.
- Mes chers concitoyens, dans les
circonstances difficiles
que traverse notre pays,
le président Muhammad Hosni Moubarak
a décidé de renoncer à sa fonction
de président de la République.
Il a confié au
Conseil supérieur des forces armées,
la direction des affaires du pays.
Qu'allah soit avec notre pays
et lui vienne en aide.
Maintenant c'est fini Moubarak !
La place Tahrir a gagné.
Les Égyptiens sont libres.
Ils ont chassé leur dictateur
en seulement 18 jours.
L'armée dirige maintenant le pays en
attendant les prochaines élections.
Entrent alors en scène
une organisation islamiste,
la confrérie des Frères musulmans.
Opposants historiques à tous les
pouvoirs égyptiens depuis les années 20.
Ils militent pour l'application
de la charia
et vont tout faire
pour prendre le pouvoir.
7 jours seulement après la
chute de Moubarak.
Leur mentor, le cheikh
Youssef Al-qaradawi, venu du Qatar,
transforme la place Tahrir
en une immense mosquée.
Le prédicateur vient récupérer la
révolution au profit de la confrérie.
Sur Al-Jazeera.
L'image d'une place Tahrir religieuse,
chasse celle du symbole de la liberté
et de l'appel à la démocratie.
La chaîne qatarie diffuse cet événement
dans tous les foyers du monde arabe.
Du Maghreb à la péninsule arabique,
Al-Jazeera orchestre dès le lendemain
de la chute de Moubarak,
la récupération de la révolution
par les Frères musulmans.
Pendant la révolution égyptienne,
j'étais tout le temps
dans les locaux d'Al-Jazeera.
Pour présenter différentes émissions.
Car la révolution doit être
continuellement encouragée.
Et les gens avaient besoin
d'écouter mes paroles.
Les frères m'ont dit :
"Vos déclarations nous ont donné
du courage et nous ont protégé.
Elles nous ont réconforté
dans notre combat,
nous sur la place Tahrir
et partout ailleurs.
Ces révolutions, nous les faisons.
Quand notre ardeur faiblit, à chaque fois,
vous reprenez la parole.
Et des gens venus de partout
nous rejoignent.
En Égypte, la lutte pour le pouvoir
va commencer.
4 jours après la démission
d'Hosni Moubarak,
la Libye est le troisième pays touché
par la vague des printemps arabes.
Sur cet immense territoire
producteur de pétrole,
10 fois moins peuplé que l'Égypte,
la Révolution commence le 15 février 2011,
ici dans la ville de Benghazi,
à l'est du pays.
Sur cette place, baptisée elle aussi,
la place Tahrir.
Pendant 40 ans, Mouammar Kadhafi
à terroriser la population,
multiplié les pendaisons,
gaspillé l'argent du pétrole
dans d'improbables
aventures militaires
et financer le terrorisme
dans le monde entier.
En Libye, à la différence
de la Tunisie et de l'Égypte,
la révolution va tourner à la
guerre et va durer 8 mois.
- Habitants de Benghazi !
Vous êtes des héros !
Réclamez vos droits !
Tout a commencé à Benghazi
par le geste fou d'un homme
descendu seul dans la rue
pour demander la chute de Kadhafi.
Le courage inouï
de ce premier manifestant
est l'étincelle qui va lancer
la révolution libyenne.
Mohamed Najem, un habitant de Benghazi
qui a participé à la révolution,
était dans la rue
à ce moment-là.
- C'était une personne
d'une quarantaine d'années,
petit de cœur, tout mince.
Le peuple réclame
la chute du régime
Révolte-toi Bengazi !
Levez-vous habitants de Bengazi !
C'est là qu'on s'est tous unis
avec cette personne
et qu'on a commencé à hurler
"le peuple veut faire tomber le régime"
Nous ne sommes pas armés !
Les premiers manifestants marchent jusqu'au
quartier général de Kadhafi à Benghazi.
Les soldats répondent
à ce rassemblement pacifique
par des tirs
à la mitrailleuse lourde.
Un des jeunes filme la scène comme
il le peut, dans la panique.
- Il y a des jeunes
qui ont enlevé leur chemise
et qui ont enlevé leur pantalon
et ils ont sauté dans la caserne,
juste pour montrer qu'on n'est pas armés,
qu'on est venus faire une révolution.
Nous, on a voulu une révolution,
mais eux, ils ont voulu une guerre,
donc, ils ont eu la guerre.
Le lendemain, les jeunes
retournent devant la caserne.
Ils se sont armés dans la nuit
de cocktails Molotov,
de pierres et d'explosifs.
Ils vont réussir l'impensable,
prendre d'assaut la caserne Alfadil,
Un des lieux de terreur dans lequel Kadhafi
faisait torturé et exécuté ses opposants.
Si c'est une conspiration intérieure
ou extérieure, nous allons l'écraser.
Si c'est un complot militaire,
nous allons l'éliminer.
Nous allons le détruire avec l'aide
du peuple libyen et des tribus libyennes
qui vont s'unir pour un seul combat,
la libération de chaque parcelle du pays.
Kadhafi envoie ses chars
écraser la ville rebelle.
Il menace son peuple, mais
il est isolé sur la scène internationale.
Un mois après le début de la révolution,
l'ONU autorise le recours à la force
pour protéger les civils libyens.
Londres et Paris
envoient des avions de chasse
détruire les blindés
qui menacent Benghazi.
Ces bombardements
au nom du droit d'ingérence
pour sauver la population libyenne,
sont aussi une occasion inespérée
pour l'Occident
de se débarrasser enfin
de Kadhafi, l'incontrôlable.
Sur Al-Jazeera, qui a pris
fait et cause pour la révolution,
le cheikh Youssef Al-qaradawi
va galvaniser les Libyens.
Le prédicateur qui avait fait prier la
place Tahrir au Caire,
prononce une fatwa contre Kadhafi.
Cet homme veut anéantir le peuple.
Et moi, je suis celui
qui protège le peuple.
J'appelle par cette fatwa tous ceux qui
peuvent le faire à lui tirer dessus,
et à débarrasser la Libye
et son noble peuple
de cet individu scélérat et dangereux.
La fatwa du cheikh al-Qaradâwî
donne le signal de la traque de Kadhafi.
Son assassinat est maintenant légal,
au nom de Dieu.
Les rebelles ont reçu
des armes du Qatar
et se sont équipés en pillant
les armureries du régime.
La chasse à l'homme commence.
Les combattants de la révolution,
malgré quelques défaites,
vont faire tomber 1 à 1 les villes libyennes
soustraites au contrôle de Kadhafi.
Les combats sont acharnés,
frontaux.
Il faut vaincre ou mourir.
Une grande majorité des jeunes s'engage
et apprend sur le terrain
à manier des armes
de toutes sortes.
Mais Kadhafi ne cède pas.
Depuis la capitale, Tripoli,
il exécute ses opposants
et envoie toujours ses chars
contre son peuple.
Il lance une vague d'arrestations
parmi les internautes
qui soutiennent le soulèvement.
On peut être arrêté pour un tweet
ou un appel relayé sur Facebook.
Mohamed Ben Lamin, peintre et sculpteur
de Misrata, est emprisonné avec son frère,
un blogueur opposant du régime,
placé sous écoutes téléphoniques.
- Ils avaient un épais dossier
où tous nos textos
et nos conversations téléphoniques
étaient regroupés et imprimés.
Il nous emmenait pour des interrogatoires
pendant lesquels il nous torturait,
ou nous menaçait avec des armes.
Certains d'entre nous
sont morts sous la torture
et d'autres à cause
du manque de soins médicaux.
Ils étaient sur les nerfs,
parce que jour après jour,
il se rendait compte
qu'il était en train de perdre la guerre.
Il devenait furieux,
et se défoulait sur nous,
les prisonniers d'Abou Slim.
Mohamed Ben Lamin est enfermé dans la
prison d'Abou Slim à Tripoli.
Entre ses murs, en 1996,
plus de 1200 prisonniers,
islamistes pour la plupart,
avaient été massacrés
par les forces spéciales de Kadhafi.
Dans cet univers qui symbolise
l'horreur du régime.
Pour ne pas devenir fou, pour tenir,
Ben lamin dessine
sur les murs de la cellule
dans laquelle il restera 4 mois
jusqu'à la fin de la guerre.
L'étau se resserre autour de Kadhafi.
Après 6 mois de combats, fin août 2011,
les brigades des révolutionnaires
venues de toutes les villes libérées,
se coordonnent et lancent
l'assaut final sur Tripoli.
Ils sont rejoints
par une troupe de 600 Libyens
rentré d'exil pour l'ultime combat.
Le dictateur vit réfugié dans son palais,
dévasté par les missiles.
Dans un dernier discours,
il fulmine contre le Qatar et Al-Jazeera,
faisant appel, en vain,
à l'unité arabe
dont il avait été le champion
adulé autrefois,
sans comprendre que la révolution
aujourd'hui se fait contre lui.
- Ces chaînes de télévision arabes
sont notre plus grand ennemi.
Elles vous encouragent à détruire les
puits de pétrole, à détruire la liberté,
à anéantir le pouvoir du peuple,
à détruire la Libye.
Mais la Libye
est une forteresse mondiale.
Est-ce que vous avez
un problème avec moi ?
Merci à nos frères du Qatar.
Est-ce que c'est ça le sang
et la fraternité qui nous lie ?
Au lieu d'être de notre côté,
vous êtes contre nous.
Mais l'heure de l'action a sonné.
En avant marche !
L'heure de la victoire a sonné.
Pas de reculade. Révolution !
Fin août, Tripoli tombe enfin
aux mains des insurgés.
Mais Kadhafi a déjà fui.
Les rebelles pillent son palais
de Bab Azizia,
un bunker immense où le dictateur
vivait entouré de son harem.
Il s'est réfugié
entouré des membres de sa tribu
et de ses mercenaires dans sa ville
natale de Syrte, pour l'ultime bataille.
Encerclé dans sa ville détruite,
Kadhafi va encore une fois
essayer de sauver sa peau.
Il va fuir avec son escorte dans un
convoi de 4x4 remplis d'armes.
Son évasion est arrêtée net
par une frappe de l'OTAN.
Celui qui avait traité les
révolutionnaires de rats
et capturé caché dans un égout.
Lynché par la foule,
Kadhafi a une mort abjecte,
à la mesure de l'horreur
qu'il inspirait.
Sans doute une manière d'exorciser
la terreur superstitieuse
qu'il exerçait
tant qu'il était vivant.
La révolution libyenne a duré 8 mois,
et aurait fait 25 000 morts.
Le 18 mars 2011,
3 mois après la Tunisie,
la Syrie est le quatrième
grand pays arabe à s'embraser.
Les Syriens descendent dans la rue
pour la liberté,
pour s'inscrire à leur tour
dans ce printemps arabe plein de promesses.
Pour demander la démocratie
dans un pays où la famille El Assad
est au pouvoir depuis 40 ans.
Les forces de sécurité tirent sur la
foule, faisant des centaines de morts,
arrêtent et torture
des milliers de manifestants.
En un mois, le mouvement
s'étend à tout le pays.
Sa répression est terrible.
Le pouvoir multiplie les massacres.
- Voilà, c'était notre maison,
qui était aussi la maison de mon frère.
Ils ont brûlé la maison de mon frère,
parce qu'il a soutenu la révolution,
parce qu'il a réclamé la liberté.
On peut même plus dormir dans nos lits.
Jusqu'au tapis sur lesquels on s'asseyait.
Tout a été brûlé.
4 mois après les premières manifestations,
un groupe d'officiers désertent
et créé l'Armée syrienne libre
pour protéger la population.
Elle recrute des volontaires
pour combattre.
Quelques commerçants, professeurs,
étudiants ou paysans
qui vont se battre comme ils le pourront
face aux tueurs professionnels du régime.
Une armée de bric et de broc.
- On a vendu tout l'or de nos femmes
pour acheter ces armes
et on y a mis toutes nos économies.
Les autres armes viennent de prises
de guerre de l'Armée syrienne libre.
J'ai quitté l'université et j'ai rejoint
l'armée libre dans mon village,
la brigade des hommes libres
de Khirbet Al-jawzi.
Si Allah le veut, soit nous vaincrons,
soit nous tomberons en martyrs.
Nous nous battrons dans la voie d'Allah
jusqu'à la dernière goutte de notre sang.
Malgré leur détermination
et leur courage,
les soldats de la première heure
de l'Armée syrienne libre
ne parviendront pas à faire tomber
Bachar el-Assad.
Le peuple syrien va devenir l'otage
d'un conflit régional qui le dépasse
et dans lequel vont s'affronter
les 2 grands courants de l'islam
les sunnites majoritaires
et les chiites iraniens
qui vont venir combattre
au côté de Bachar el-Assad.
- L'union mondiale
des savants musulmans,
a déclaré qu'il devait y avoir
un soulèvement contre Bachar el Assad.
Il doit être arrêté, et tué.
Le cheikh Youssef al-Qaradâwî intervient,
comme il l'avait fait en Égypte,
et en Libye,
en direct sur Al-Jazeera.
Dans son émission La Charia et la vie,
il appelle à nouveau
à l'élimination du dictateur.
Une façon d'installer dans chaque pays,
dès le début des révolutions,
les Frères musulmans,
au cœur de la conquête du pouvoir.
Leur sponsor est le Qatar.
Le cheikh Qaradawi,
chef spirituel des Frères musulmans,
joue un rôle fondamental dans l'alliance
de la confrérie avec le Qatar.
Égyptien naturalisé qatari,
il vit à Doha,
où l'émir a mis à sa disposition
la chaîne de télévision Al-Jazeera,
devenue sa tribune médiatique.
Le Qatar joue un rôle central
dans ces révolutions.
Il est rapidement devenu le porte
drapeau de toutes les révolutions.
Que ce soit en Égypte, en Libye,
au Yémen.
Il leur a offert de l'argent,
des hommes, les médias.
Il leur a offert tout ce dont
elle avait besoin sur le plan politique.
L'émir du Qatar s'est senti menacé
par les révolutions,
la peur de les voir se propager
aux monarchies du Golfe Persique.
Plutôt que de les combattre,
il a choisi de les contrôler
et a financé les Frères musulmans
comme il achète des équipes de football.
Le Qatar se retrouve dans leur idéologie
religieuse et conservatrice.
Il voit en eux le meilleur moyen d'établir
sur le nouveau monde arabe
une domination politique qui serait enfin
à la hauteur de sa puissance financière.
En Égypte, les Frères musulmans vont
mettre plus d'un an à conquérir le pouvoir.
Les révolutionnaires, eux,
ont quitté la place.
Les jeunes activistes
se sont dispersés,
incapables de s'organiser
dans la lutte politique.
Depuis le départ de Moubarak,
les forces armées dirigent le pays.
Les Frères musulmans apparaissent
comme la seule force alternative.
La Confrérie est une organisation
disciplinée et structurée
par des années de clandestinité.
Elle offre depuis des années
à la population démunie,
des services sociaux,
des dispensaires médicaux, des écoles.
Pour de nombreux Égyptiens,
elle remplace depuis longtemps déjà,
un État défaillant et corrompu.
Gamal el-Ghitany est un
des plus grands écrivains égyptiens,
souvent menacé de mort par
les islamistes les plus radicaux,
dont il dénonce la violence
et le terrorisme.
- Les Frères musulmans n'avaient,
au départ,
aucun rapport avec la révolution,
bien au contraire.
Pendant les 4 premiers jours,
on ne les a pas vus sur la place Tahrir.
Il n'y avait que quelques jeunes
Frères musulmans venus à titre individuel
qui s'étaient rebellés
contre leur hiérarchie.
Les frères ne sont sortis
que lorsqu'ils ont compris
que la vague était
suffisamment puissante
et qu'elle pourrait leur permettre
de réaliser leur projet.
En novembre 2011, quelques Égyptiens
s'installent à nouveau place Tahrir
à la veille des élections législatives,
pour réclamer au pouvoir
un scrutin transparent.
Pour les militaires
qui dirigent le pays,
l'ordre doit régner
et le temps n'est plus aux manifestations.
5000 policiers et militaires des forces
anti-émeutes
attaquent un campement
de 200 personnes place Tahrir.
Ulcérés par cette agression,
les jeunes redescendent dans la rue.
C'est la bataille
de l'avenue Mohamed Mahmoud.
Elle durera 5 jours
et fera 58 morts.
D'autres violences vont suivre.
Sur les murs du Caire, le soutien gorge bleu
de la jeune manifestante bastonnée,
va devenir le symbole
de la déchéance de l'armée.
Le général Ahmed Chafik,
dernier premier ministre de Moubarak
et candidat de l'armée
aux futures élections présidentielles,
ne s'en relèvera pas.
Les Frères musulmans s'imposent
en alternative crédible.
Ils remportent même
les élections législatives.
La confrérie infiltrée dans tous les
échelons de la société,
va pousser son candidat Mohamed Morsi
vers la présidence de la République.
- Je soutiens le docteur Mohamed Morsi.
Il a une excellente
interprétation de l'islam.
Et il le gère parfaitement.
Je ne vois aucune raison pour
que quiconque ait peur de l'islam.
En juin 2012,
les Égyptiens votent
pour le second tour
des élections présidentielles
dans la province du Fayoum,
à 100 kilomètres au sud du Caire,
bastion des Frères musulmans.
Les électeurs se sont mobilisés.
- J'ai voté pour la personne qui
garantira un état laïque.
Parce qu'on a besoin
d'entrées d'argent pour le pays,
de tourisme, de commerce.
Une personne
qui développera notre pays.
Il nous faut un État laïque.
Vous avez bien compris
pour qui j'ai voté.
- Le docteur Morsi est un homme bien
et nous espérons qu'il pourra nous aider.
Et nous le surveillerons.
Et à la première erreur,
nous lui dirons non, ça suffit,
vous devez changer votre équipe.
Enfin, on espère.
- Je dois bien préciser
qu'il s'agit de ton avis personnel.
- Attends, tu n'intègres pas
la politique dans la religion, compris ?
Tu restes dans la politique.
Soit, tu parles de politique,
soit, tu es en dehors.
- C'est bon, j'exprime mon opinion.
- Il exprime l'opinion d'un seul individu,
c'est clair ?
- La plupart des gens
sont d'accord avec moi.
Les autres, là,
ont un point de vue différent
car ils appartiennent à l'Ancien
régime.
Ils veulent que l'ancien régime
reste au pouvoir. Ce sont des profiteurs.
Ils ont suffisamment volé
et on veut que ça cesse.
Et Morsi va gagner, c'est sûr.
Dès le soir du second tour, les Frères
musulmans revendiquent la victoire.
Ils envoient leurs partisans
occuper la place Tahrir
par peur d'un coup d'État militaire.
La place, symbole de la révolution,
est maintenant remplie
d'hommes barbus et de femmes voilées.
- Gloire à Allah.
Le sang des martyrs n'a pas coulé en vain.
Je dis au docteur Morsi :
"Vous êtes maintenant le seul protecteur
de chacun de nous, Égyptien,
du musulman et du non-musulman".
Nous allons montrer au monde entier,
comment, quand l'islam gouverne.
il gouverne par la justice,
il gouverne par la liberté,
et il gouverne par la justice sociale.
Ils sont même rejoints
par quelques jeunes d'extrême gauche
qui ont voté Morsi
par haine du général Chafiq.
- On est sur la place Tahrir
pour qu'on se souvienne
de la ferveur révolutionnaire
contre Chafiq,
pour fêter la chute de l'ancien Régime, de
la dictature permanente de la bureaucratie.
Parce que pour la première fois
depuis 7000 ans,
nous avons un président élu
grâce à la légitimité révolutionnaire.
- Le peuple a voté en majorité
pour les Frères musulmans,
qui ont été des prédateurs
de la révolution.
Ils ont réussi, car les jeunes rebelles
n'étaient pas organisés.
Les jeunes de Facebook
qui ont lancé la révolution
se sont ensuite divisés
en de nombreux groupes.
Certains d'entre eux sont devenus
des stars de talk show télévisé.
D'autres sont rentrés au Parlement,
comme député.
Et aujourd'hui, ils sont dispersés.
Le candidat des Frères musulmans
n'a gagné qu'avec 51,7% des voix.
L'Égypte reste donc un pays
profondément divisé,
dont le peuple n'hésite plus
à descendre dans la rue.
Face à la crise économique, au chômage,
les Frères vont devoir prouver
que leur islam est la solution.
En juillet 2012,
un mois après les Égyptiens,
les Libyens votent à leur tour.
Après 8 mois de guerre,
la reconstruction est un immense défi
dans un pays où Kadhafi
avait détruit toutes les institutions.
Politiquement,
après 40 années de dictature,
comment reconstruire un pays
en quelques mois ?
Pour aider à marcher vers la démocratie
que la Libye n'a jamais connue,
l'ONU a fourni
du matériel électoral en kit
avec ses isoloirs en carton
et ses urnes de plastique.
Les Libyens vont élire
leur première Assemblée nationale.
Le soir des élections
sur la place verte de Tripoli,
c'est la fête dans un pays
où aucun habitant en âge de voter,
n'avait jamais pu choisir lui-même
librement ses représentants.
Les dirigeants des puissantes tribus,
celles de Zintane,
dans la montagne de l'Ouest,
comme celle des montagnes de l'Est,
près de Benghazi,
s'estiment exclus du processus,
alors qu'ils ont lancé la Révolution.
Ils ne font qu'une confiance limitée
aux nouveaux élus de Tripoli,
chacun cherchant à jouer le plus grand rôle
dans la Libye nouvelle
et se méfiant des autres.
- La Libye est une société,
avant d'être une organisation politique.
Et il faut maintenant que cette société
se mette au service de l'État.
Notre réalité sociale se heurte
au concept même de la démocratie.
Elle ne peut pas s'appliquer
aux sociétés Arabes,
parce qu'elle a été conçue pour
des sociétés civiles
Occidentales Libérales.
- Pour nous, les idéologies libérales
sont très difficiles à accepter.
Elles sont appréciées par les jeunes,
mais nous n'en voulons pas.
Il va y avoir un affrontement
entre le libéralisme et la politique.
Voilà ce qui nous menace.
Car nous ne sommes pas des démocrates.
Nous n'avons jamais vécu
dans une atmosphère démocratique.
Aujourd'hui en Libye,
le pays est ingouvernable.
Une coalition d'une cinquantaine
de partis politiques
a remporté les élections
sans réussir à former une majorité.
L'argent du pétrole
suscite toutes les convoitises.
Chaque région productrice
veut en contrôler les revenus.
Il n'y a plus d'armée ni de police.
La réalité du pouvoir
est détenue par les tribus,
mais aussi, depuis la guerre,
par les milices.
Certaines sont affiliées à Al-Qaïda.
Elles ont récupéré
d'énormes stocks d'armes
et refusent de se soumettre
à l'autorité de l'État.
En Tunisie ont été organisées
le 23 octobre 2011,
les premières élections
qui faisaient suite au Printemps arabe.
Dans ce pays,
la laïcité reste profondément ancrée
dans la classe moyenne
des grandes villes.
Le parti Ennahda, issu des Frères musulmans,
est arrivé en tête,
mais sans avoir la majorité.
Les Frères ont bénéficié, comme en Égypte,
du prestige de la répression
dont ils ont été victimes
sous la dictature.
C'est la victoire d'un parti discipliné
face à l'éparpillement des partis laïcs.
À Sidi Bouzid, la petite ville
où l'immolation de Mohamed Bouazizi
a donné le départ des printemps arabes.
La situation sociale n'a pas
fondamentalement changé
depuis que le parti Ennahdha
dirige le pays.
Le chômage n'a fait qu'augmenter.
On a statufié la charrette du marchand
ambulant sur la place du gouvernorat,
là où il s'est immolé.
Mais l'esprit de la révolution est loin.
- Les habitants de Sidi Bouzid trouvent
que leur région reste marginalisée.
Et ceux, depuis des années.
Nos infrastructures sont les pires
et les plus vétustes
de toute la République.
Le taux de pauvreté
y est toujours particulièrement élevé,
ainsi que le taux de chômage.
Tous les jeunes sont touchés.
Et le nombre de jeunes diplômés chômeurs
augmente tous les ans de plus de 5000.
Dans ce berceau des printemps arabes,
les associations de diplômés chômeurs
rassemblent les jeunes universitaires
qui ne trouvent pas de travail.
Souvent engagé à l'extrême gauche.
Ce sont elles,
avec les syndicalistes locaux,
qui ont transformé
l'immolation spectaculaire de Bouazizi
en un mouvement de révolution.
Aujourd'hui, ces révolutionnaires
de la première heure, se sentent trahis,
et restent mobilisés contre le pouvoir.
- Avant, nous pouvions espérer
un salaire de 5000 ou 10 000 dinars,
ce qui nous assurait un minimum.
Aujourd'hui, nous ne pouvons même plus
espérer gagner une telle somme.
Et cela a des conséquences
sur toutes nos conditions de vie.
Vous voulez un autre exemple ?
On peut rester célibataire
jusqu'à 40 ans en Tunisie. Pourquoi ?
Moi-même, je suis célibataire alors que
j'ai 34 ans et ce n'est pas par choix.
J'aimerais bien me marier,
mais je n'en ai pas les moyens matériels.
Le mariage, c'est des responsabilités.
Une femme et des enfants à nourrir.
Et vu les conditions actuelles,
c'est impossible.
- Chaque fois que nous voulons défendre
une revendication sociale,
nos manifestations sont contrées
par les salafistes.
Je suis sûr
qu'on les laisse faire délibérément.
Ils font ce qu'ils veulent.
Ils attaquent les foules, le peuple,
tous ceux qui défendent la liberté,
la dignité
et tous ceux qui essaient juste de vivre.
Les salafistes sont des intégristes
violents qui militent
pour l'islamisation totale de la société.
Ils sont soutenus par l'Arabie saoudite.
Leur stratégie consiste à récupérer
le mécontentement social
avec un slogan simpliste,
l'Islam est la solution.
Ils veulent éliminer les militants
de la gauche laïque
et font pression sur le parti
au pouvoir Ennahda.
Devant la mosquée,
ils organisent des quêtes
pour leurs frères de Syrie
pris dans la guerre.
Ces fanatiques militent pour
l'islamisation des révolutions arabes.
Les salafistes de Sidi-bouzid appartiennent
au mouvement des partisans de la charia.
Un groupe radical dirigé par Abou Iyadh,
qui a travaillé avec Ben Laden et Al Qaïda.
Ces intégristes ont imposé leur imam
à la tête de la grande mosquée de la ville.
- Notre volonté est d'arriver
à faire triompher la religion.
Nous sommes de jeunes pratiquants,
nous sommes très nombreux,
et nous ne voulons pas de la démocratie
qui n'est pas reconnue par l'islam.
Cette démocratie délègue
le pouvoir au peuple
et si le peuple veut désobéir à Allah,
il le peut.
Pour nous, il faut obéir à Allah,
le Tout-Puissant,
que ce soit lui qui régisse tout,
les petites choses comme les grandes.
À Tunis,
le Premier ministre Hamadi Jebali,
peine à gouverner son pays,
pris entre 2 feux.
D'un côté,
la pression intégriste salafiste,
difficile à gérer pour ce partisan
déclaré d'un islamisme dit modéré,
et de l'autre, le défi de l'aggravation
de la situation sociale
qui fait dire aux Tunisiens
que rien n'a changé depuis la révolution.
- C'est pas facile,
il faut être réaliste.
Ils savent très bien que ce sont des
problèmes structuraux.
C'est pas conjoncturel.
Ils oublient qu'on a vraiment hérité
de tous ces problèmes
et que ces problèmes
se sont amplifiés maintenant.
Par la révolution elle-même.
C'est-à-dire, on a libéré les voix,
on a libéré la demande,
on libère les espoirs.
Il y a un plafond maintenant.
La barre est placée très haut.
Sur le front des libertés publiques,
pour rassurer notamment
les partis de la gauche laïque
de sa coalition gouvernementale.
Hamadi Jebali a créé un ministère des
droits de l'homme, une première en Tunisie.
Il a confié le portefeuille à Samir Dilou,
un membre d'Ennahdha,
qui peine à convaincre de l'utilité
de son cabinet.
Le ministre des Droits de l'homme
va vite devoir faire ses preuves
face à la multiplication
des exactions extrémistes
qui perturbent la vie politique tunisienne.
Les salafistes attaquent toutes les formes
d'expression des libertés individuelles.
Ils s'opposent à l'islam populaire
tunisien.
Eux qui veulent soumettre la population à
l'intégrisme, considèrent les marabouts,
ces tombeaux des saints de l'islam
comme de l'hérésie.
Ces mausolées sont une cible
de ces fanatiques
qui ont dynamité de nombreux autres lieux
de religion populaire à travers la Tunisie.
L'alcool et la liberté des mœurs
sont honnis par les salafistes.
En septembre 2012, ils ont saccagé
l'hôtel Horchani à Sidi Bouzid.
Inauguré en mars 1976, à l'époque
où la Tunisie se réclamait de la laïcité.
C'était le dernier lieu
où l'on vendait de la bière légalement,
dans la bourgade où est née la Révolution.
- Ils sont venus casser le bar.
Casser toutes les bouteilles.
Ils ont monté aux chambres,
ils ont cassé les chambres.
Ils ont enfoncé les chambres carrément.
Ils ont cassé tout les salons du bar.
Ils étaient aussi à la réception,
ils ont tout cassé.
- Depuis la révolution,
depuis la mort de Bouazizi,
vous êtes vous demandé combien
de personnes ont fini ivres mortes ?
Combien de morts complètement saouls ?
Il y en a plein !
Combien de personnes suicidées
parce qu'elles étaient ivres ? Beaucoup !
Combien de buveurs
ont mal agi avec leurs parents ?
Combien de personnes
ont commis des délits,
des crimes après avoir
consommé de l'alcool ?
Et surtout, combien de femmes
ont été enlevées et violées
par des hommes ivres ?
Les artistes
sont une autre cible des salafistes.
En juin 2012, ils ont saccagé une
exposition dans la banlieue de Tunis
dont ils jugeaient les œuvres exposées
offensantes pour l'islam.
Parmi celles-ci, l'installation
de la sculptrice Nadia Jelassi.
3 mannequins de femmes voilées
émergeant d'un monticule de pierres,
enveloppées dans des journaux
contenant de la propagande islamiste.
L'œuvre évoque les lapidations des femmes
soupçonnée d'adultère en Afghanistan.
Non seulement les fanatiques
l'ont dénoncé comme une incitation
à jeter des pierres aux femmes voilées,
mais en plus,
ils ont déposé plainte
pour trouble à l'ordre public.
- Un jour, je reçois un coup de fil,
d'une dame qui se présente
en tant que secrétaire
du juge d'instruction
qui me demande si je voulais bien
me présenter devant le juge.
Et il me reçoit et il me dit
"Madame, vous êtes accusée
pour avoir exposé des images entraînant
la perturbation de l'ordre public".
Si l'instruction arrive jusqu'au procès,
ça serait une première en Tunisie.
Une sorte de jurisprudence.
Ça serait la première fois où un artiste,
irait en prison
pour avoir exposé un travail.
Et les frontières, c'est à moi de les
définir et à personne d'autre,
à aucun pouvoir, ni politique,
ni religieux, ni aucun autre pouvoir.
Et ça, c'est mon espace de liberté.
Ça, c'est mon être au monde.
Personne ne peut me l'enlever.
- Personnellement,
je me retrouve devant un malaise énorme.
Pour moi, traduire un créateur en justice
pour une œuvre d'art,
c'est un affront à la révolution
et aux principes de la révolution.
Le problème, c'est qu'on est en face
d'une justice qu'on veut indépendante.
Je me sens un peu avec les bras liés,
mais je vais tout faire
pour dépasser cet épisode
avec les moindres dégâts.
Mais je crains que le mal
est déjà fait.
Et pour moi, une Tunisie qui se respecte,
doit respecter ses créateurs.
Si Samir Dilou,
le ministre des Droits de l'homme,
témoigne d'un malaise impuissant,
D'autres, au sein d'Ennahda,
souhaitent que la justice poursuive
les atteintes au sacré.
Rached Ghannouchi,
le chef du parti d'Ennahdha,
véritable homme fort de la Tunisie,
décrié par les laïcs pour
ses relations ambiguës avec les salafistes,
condamne fermement
toutes les libertés prises avec l'islam.
- Pour vivre
dans une société pacifiquement,
il faut que chacun d'entre nous
respecte les croyances des autres.
Vous avez la liberté de croire
ou de ne pas croire en l'islam et au Coran.
Ou même d'y apporter
une critique scientifique.
Mais vous n'avez pas le droit
de vous en moquer,
comme en écrivant le nom d'Allah,
sur la semelle de vos chaussures,
ou en imprimant des versets du Coran
sur des sous-vêtements.
Alors pourquoi
faire des choses pareilles ?
Ce sont des actes diaboliques.
Des actes diaboliques
qui ne servent qu'à une chose,
provoquer les musulmans.
Les révolutionnaires
qui ont chassé Ben Ali,
ne s'opposaient pas
à la laïcité tunisienne.
Ils dénonçaient simplement
la dictature.
Dans la Tunisie d'aujourd'hui,
le parti islamiste au pouvoir
et les salafistes,
attaquent le modèle laïque
hérité de l'indépendance en 1956.
Avant la révolution,
on ne voyait pas autant
de femmes voilées
dans les rues de Tunis.
Le port du niqab est devenu une des
principales revendications des islamistes.
Une prise en otage des femmes
pour mieux attaquer les idéaux
de la révolution
encore vivace dans ce pays.
La Tunisie est divisée
par 2 conceptions de la société.
Elle est menacée par la rupture.
Ces victoires des Frères musulmans
sont un triomphe pour le Qatar.
L'émirat peut passer à la phase suivante
de sa stratégie politique,
devenir le leader de ce nouveau monde arabe,
islamique et sunnite.
Pour ce petit pays,
c'est une stratégie d'alliance ambitieuse
pour assurer sa sécurité
face à ses puissants voisins
saoudiens et iraniens.
Pour servir ses intérêts diplomatiques,
le Qatar organise en septembre 2012
dans l'hôtel Sheraton de Doha,
2 conférences pour tenter de convaincre
les laïcs arabes de collaborer
avec les Frères musulmans
à la constitution
d'une grande nation islamique.
Les vedettes en sont les principaux
dirigeants des Frères musulmans,
des radicaux qui, il y a peu,
tenaient la démocratie
pour la pire des impiétés.
Khaled Mechaal, du Hamas palestinien
favorable à la destruction d'Israël.
Rached Ghannouchi de Tunisie,
Hassan El Tourabi du Soudan,
Ex-soutien d'Al Qaïda,
Al-bayanouni de Syrie.
Tous réunis avec la même ambition,
créer une grande nation arabe sunnite
dominée par les Frères musulmans.
Une occasion unique pour le monde arabe
de créer un grand ensemble politique,
une ambition à laquelle Al-Jazeera
travaille depuis sa création.
Wadah Khanfar a dirigé la chaîne
depuis la guerre d'Irak en 2005,
jusqu'à septembre 2011.
- Je pense que nous allons enfin
pouvoir établir des relations communes
dans toute la région.
Nous allons construire une société
fidèle à notre culture.
Qui est vieille de 1300 ou 1400 ans.
Nous allons enfin prendre en main
notre propre évolution,
dont le pivot sera régional.
On ne suivra plus les modèles
occidentaux ou bien soviétiques,
ni aucun autre.
Pour accomplir ce rêve de création
d'une grande nation arabe sunnite,
il manque au Qatar un dernier pays allié,
la Syrie.
La Syrie est le seul pays
des printemps arabes,
qui n'a pas réussi à chasser son tyran.
La révolution est dure depuis 2 ans,
et le dictateur Bachar el-Assad
n'est toujours pas tombé.
La révolte est devenue
une guerre civile meurtrière
qui a fait près de 80 000 morts.
1 million de Syriens ont fui leur pays.
La guerre est totale.
Elle a frappé partout, dans les campagnes
comme dans toutes les grandes villes.
Le souk d'Alep, le plus ancien du monde,
a été détruit.
La vieille ville est restée des mois
prise sous les tirs des snipers
de Bachar al-Assad.
Le principal atout militaire du régime
est la puissance de son armée de l'air.
Ses avions de chasse bombardent à l'aveugle
les zones de combat comme les habitations.
Les pilotes d'hélicoptères larguent
des barils remplis de TNT et de ferraille.
Les barres à 1000.
Imprécis, mais très dévastateurs,
ils soufflent les immeubles
et tuent les habitants.
Une arme de terreur.
- Je dormais, quant à l'aube, un avion
a largué un baril de TNT sur notre maison.
La maison de mes beaux-parents
et l'a détruite.
Mon frère a perdu la vie,
ainsi que sa femme et ma belle-mère.
Mon second frère et moi,
nous avons été blessés.
Le village a été bombardé
avec plusieurs barils de TNT,
et 15 personnes y ont perdu la vie
en une seule matinée.
- Vive Bachar !
Les Assad gouvernent depuis 1970
par la force.
Bachar el-Assad a succédé à son père
en juillet 2000.
Il a hérité d'un pouvoir
assis sur la puissance d'un parti unique,
d'un service de renseignements à ses ordres
et d'une communauté soudée.
Les Alaouites, une secte chiite.
À la différence de Mouammar Kadhafi
qui combattait seul les révolutionnaires,
Bachar el-Assad a de grands alliés,
les Russes et les Chinois
engagés dans un rapport de force
avec l'Occident et les chiites iraniens.
Téhéran aide le régime depuis le début de
la révolte en Syrie,
un soutien sans faille,
diplomatique et militaire.
Nous remercions en premier la Russie,
la Chine et l'Iran.
Et tous les autres pays qui nous soutiennent
face aux tentatives d'ingérence
dans les affaires intérieures syriennes.
Le peuple syrien les assure
de son admiration
et de sa fidélité
et de sa reconnaissance.
Les alliés de Bachar al-Assad
ont bloqué le vote de résolution de l'ONU
qui aurait pu autoriser
une intervention de l'OTAN, comme en Libye.
La faiblesse du soutien occidental
à l'insurrection,
s'explique aussi
par la proximité d'Israël, du Liban,
et la peur de voir un État islamiste
succéder à Bachar el-Assad.
L'armée syrienne libre, créée pour résister
à la répression sanglante du régime,
c'est renforcé.
Des milliers de soldats et d'officiers
de l'armée régulière de Bachar al-Assad
ont déserté et rejoignent ses rangs.
Chaque déserteur officialise sa défection
en postant une vidéo sur YouTube.
Elle permet de dater,
cartes d'identité à l'appui,
le jour de son incorporation
dans l'Armée syrienne libre.
- Je suis le colonel de l'armée de l'air
Kassem Mohammed Saad Eddine, né à Rastan,
près de Homs.
Et voici ma carte d'identité.
Le colonel Kassem, comme la majorité
des officiers
qui a rejoint l'Armée syrienne libre,
à une vision laïque
et démocratique de son pays.
Il est aujourd'hui le responsable militaire
de la ville de Homs.
- Le monde entier observe passivement
les destructions et les tueries.
Les calculs diplomatiques et
les règlements de comptes entre les États,
se font au détriment du peuple syrien.
Tout ça, c'est à cause de l'importance
stratégique de la Syrie dans la région.
Et c'est pour cette raison
que la victoire tarde à venir.
Si personne ne vient nous soutenir,
la situation va empirer
non seulement en Syrie,
mais aussi dans tout le Proche-Orient.
L'occident sera incapable
de contrôler cette région,
qui sombrera dans l'extrémisme.
L'attentisme des Occidentaux
à laisser la main libre au Qatar,
avec l'Arabie Saoudite,
ils financent des groupes extrémistes,
des combattants islamistes,
qui affrontent les milices
de Bachar el-Assad
au nom du djihad.
Ces groupes djihadistes syriens sont
les plus riches et les mieux armés
et ils jouent un rôle déterminant
dans les opérations militaires.
Eux aussi diffusent
des vidéos sur Internet.
Les films de leurs attentats.
Pour impressionner leurs bailleurs de fonds,
du Golfe.
Et pour attirer des combattants
du monde entier.
Après l'Afghanistan et l'Irak,
la Syrie est devenue à son tour
une terre du djihad.
Dans les mosquées salafistes des
pays alentour,
les imams recrutent déjà des combattants
pour la nouvelle guerre sainte,
comme ici au Liban.
- La sauvagerie du régime syrien
contre le peuple,
dans l'indifférence du monde
a conduit les Syriens
à croire au djihad
et à se battre.
Les hommes, les vieux, les femmes
et les enfants ont pris les armes.
Il y a un an,
les Syriens étaient un peuple mort.
Il a suffi d'une année
pour en faire un peuple djihadiste.
Avec l'aide des renforts djihadistes,
des régions se libèrent 1 à 1 en Syrie
et au fil des villages reconquis,
les combattants de la guerre sainte
sont acclamés en libérateurs
par la population.
En Syrie,
le régime finira sûrement par tomber,
mais à quel prix ?
Entre la dictature et le salafisme,
la voie reste étroite
pour la démocratie dans le monde arabe.
Les populations qui ont chassé
leurs dictateurs,
vont-elles se satisfaire des gouvernements
islamistes qu'elles ont élus ?
En Égypte et en Tunisie, des manifestants
sont à nouveau descendus dans la rue
pour exprimer leur mécontentement.
L'histoire des révolutions
arabes n'est pas jouée.
Le désir de justice sociale des
populations toujours touchées
par le chômage et la pauvreté
reste fort.
La confiscation des idéaux révolutionnaires,
qui avaient fait des printemps arabes
un moment d'espoir
pour le monde entier.
Sera-t-elle sans retour ?